first
thank you daniela thanks for having us
here
so so i will actually cover a line of
work on this direction and this is
some joint collaboration with some of
the uh people that are listed here
besides the two of us gilbert baumgland
kevin
uh ludwig vladimir spierlane and vlad uh
wes william skip the third
so since is a friday afternoon and is
our last
talk of the great workshop i guess
everybody is by now tired of the great
technical talk and let me take a minute
to thanks the organizer for this great
event
i
uh so i i just wanna give
a you know a brief uh highlight of the
the the topic that i will cover in this
talk so so that if you have to leave at
least you know
what is going to happen during the rest
of the slide uh so the goal that we seek
to achieve is to find
alternative intractability assumption
such in from combinatorial group theory
such that well first of all we would
like to use them for some cryptographic
application
and second we would like to have some
evidence to establish some evidence
about the hardness of this assumption
and in particular in our specific case
we will introduce a new intractability
assumption and we will prove some random
self-reducibility property about this
new assumption and we our approach that
we decide to follow it was a bit
different than what has been done with
the previous group theoretic approach in
the sense that we want to start with
some that we all know and love which is
a learning uh with errors and we are
gonna try to generalize this notion and
then in particular we are gonna
instantiate this generalization to a
specific
class specific class of groups
non-non-commutative groups
and so what are the groups so this was a
long discussion with one of my
collaborators gilbert bounce glab
bombslag that he was a
great
theoretician group theoretician which
unfortunately died recently and we all
these uh we all had this amazing
discussion and one day say okay what
about uh looking at uh these bonsai
groups so we were discussing all the
property that really we wanted from a
cryptographic point of view and say okay
what about
burnside groups and me and say okay what
about them
so i guess since uh you know from my
perspective we all are not very familiar
with these burnside groups what i'm
going to do is start with a background
on these barsight groups
and then follow with the description of
the generalization of the lwe assumption
that we call learning varsity
homomorphism with noise
and then antonio will discuss the
hardness the random self-reducibility of
this new assumption and if time permits
he will also
describe some of the application of this
assumption
okay so so let's start with birth side
groups well these in the group theory
community they have been studied
extensively they are not new groups so
for them they have been looking at them
for a long time but from a different
perspective so what they are looking at
is uh
if i give you a group and the order uh
of the elements in this group they
if it's finite so all the element in
this group i've found it order what
about
the finiteness of the group is that
necessarily the group found it or not
so this is one of the question that they
they look in this setting or
alternatively what the combinatorial
structure of these groups
so
so let let's see an informal definition
of the bonsai groups so i'm gonna denote
with this symbol b and m
for the most generic group with n
generators
where the order of all the elements
divide m
and
so we the generator i'm going to use the
notation just x1 x2 xn so if you like
you can think of them like the
in a multivariate polynomial
and the elements in this group
is just a sequence of generators in the
inverse
one after the other
and the
in this group
is the empty sequence
and the most important condition is the
following for every element in the group
b and m
the element to the exponent m is equal
to the identity in the group
and since we are using the
multiplication notation then i'm using
just
w m equal to one
okay
so so i will say this group have been
studied a lot
and analyzing the characteristic of this
group is not so easy so not a lot is
known for these bonsai groups so in the
specific case for example of
m the exponent equals to two this is
known this group is finite
and it it's in particular is a billion
and you can think this is isomorphic to
the then vector space over f2 so this is
actually something that we can think of
this as a familiar object but what about
m equals 3 well equal 3 is also
well studied and we know a lot about it
it's finite so this is already a good
thing that one of the properties that we
discussed we wanted it's finite
good is non-commutative so at least we
move away from the billion case
otherwise it's kind of
not our point and is not isomorphic to
f3n so so that that's no this is in fact
much larger
uh and then when we move uh for higher
value of them again things get very
complicated well four is kind of easy we
know it's it's funny because you can see
these as a combination of the other two
smaller groups and same thing for six
but then if you start by considering
equal five or seven people don't know is
it fun at infinite i don't know so so
then we move to the other side of the
spectrum for m large and here i am large
really what i mean is on the order of
100 something like that just for every
specific numbering in mind then the bar
side group will become infinite
the question is if this group is finite
for every n
so you fix you fix the exponent and that
yeah
so so even though so i give you a group
and the order of the group is fi so the
order of all the element is finite
is it this group
infinite or finite
infinite family of groups depending on
how many
in particular for i'm large then you you
in this case of bonsai group b and m for
m
large is infinite
yeah
so
so so
okay so we
we looked at this bird's eye group and
say okay where do we start well we start
from the first one that is not the
the familiar one
so it's finite which is our first one of
our main prediction is not commutative
so let's start from this one so for the
rest of the talk i'm gonna focus to m
equals three and for brevity i'll just
denote as bn
uh okay so so if i write again the
definition essentially the only things
that
we have changed is again with the
generator are x 1 x 2 x and the 11th are
sequence of the generator and the
inverse
and the exponent condition just says w 3
equal 1 but now w 3 what does it mean
the concatenation of w3 times so www
is equal to 1.
and so i put the most generic inquire so
what do i mean by most generic the most
generic means that the only non-trivial
identity in bien are the one that follow
from the exponent condition and that's
it
uh so two important consequence of these
is that bien is not commutative because
if you wanna
look at element x1 xj well the only way
i can get a 1 is by length 3 of
something of length 3. so i only have to
generate or so it's not going to be
commutative so so x i x j is not equal
to x j x i for every i different than j
and the group operation is defined
formally as the so if i if i have two
elements w one and w two multiply two
element it just means
um you know put w1 and then following w2
so just the concatenation but when you
put two words one next to the other at
the border of the end of w1 at the
beginning of w2 you may have some
simplification so what you get is the
product of these uh two words w1 and w2
so
so so
bn is as i said the previous is not
commutative but we are kind of used to
the
this commutative property so is there
some hope that maybe i can reach some
sort of commutativity and so one thing
that i notice is that if i define what
is called the two commutator which is
this symbol of the pair of these x i x j
then i can get something close to the uh
the commutativity in particular i get
that x i x j is equal to x j x i
concatenated this extra uh value that is
called the two commutator so i say that
you know i get the commutative with my
extra
payoff
so so i get the equality but with an
extra term
and then you can also similarly define
the tricommutator which is the
commutator with three elements which
surprise not surprisingly is the
commutator of the first two element and
then the commutator with the third
element
in this case
okay
well you can
in general extend this definition of
commutator to l
element but for the specific group that
we are focusing b and remember where m
is fixed to b3 then in this case
we have these important equality we
which the commutator will wait for so
the commutator with four element is
equal to one so essentially the sequence
stops there it wait for
so so of course you can stop me at any
time antonio will be happy to answer all
the questions
so
okay so
so what are the important property of um
property that follow from this equality
that x i x j x k s a x h is equal to one
first of all that the commutator of
weight three so the three computator
commutes with everything so this is
really good so it means that if i have a
word then somehow i wanna swap the three
commutator with another element i don't
have to pay any
payload i can just swap it and nothing
will happen so this is something that we
like yes
is it easy to explain why the uh for
uh so
it's like it's not difficult
but it require a proof i can do it
offline but it is you know it's a line
but but it's not uh it require a proof
this is what you had before in the
previous slide yeah
sorry
so
so you you have to prove but you can
prove
that
if you put if you consider the
commutator a weight four so x one x
three 2x3 x4
this is equal to 1
and again with the proof
you can which i'm omitting for the sake
of of time in the talk but i can do it
on the board if you want
that
that this implies that if i consider
a commutator away three these
uh commute with everything and it
doesn't add any extra element in the
sequence so what is the best way to
think of these commutators
in the previous slide
yeah so
sorry i'm going forward
so as a
for for weight two
this is the element
such that if you add these
on this equality it will make
x i equals x x j equal to x j x i
because that the way we define the
commutator weight 2 is equal to x i
inverse
x j inverse x i x j so if you plug this
in here
essentially you have that x inverse
simplify this x i
x j inverse
grid of this one so you get the the
quality
of three commutators what's the property
of the three commutators the the three
pro the properties that
um
so the commutator you can think of the
three commutator as the commutator of
the first two
and then so in that case it will be x
inverse x j inverse x i x j
and then the result you do the
commutator way too with x k i see how to
build it
it's something that if you multiply x i
j k by the commutator then you get a
rotation
yeah
so and notice in particular that in
versailles groups it would be equivalent
to define
the three commutator f x i commutator
the x j x k but in general is not true
but for this
parasite group is true
okay so so
the first important problem that we're
gonna need for the uh next point is that
the commutator weight tree swap with
everything and the other important
property that again with the proof
followed by the fact that the commutator
of weight four is equal to one is that
uh two commutators
commute among themselves so i don't have
to pay anything when i swap two
commutators and i do have other uh
property that are useful for the proof
but let me skip it because we are not
going to use it in the talk but i just
put it there
for the recording essentially but i what
i wanna point out
in this point is that
for uh for simplicity we are going to
assume that within
the commutator the order of the
generators is lexicographic
so they are older in lexicographic or if
you want to swap
x i with xj within the commutator then
these will affect the exponent
by a minus sign
okay so so
now really if i if i have to deal with
this element
i really have to uh look at this
structure
so but somehow i need some hope that uh
in this specific group that i'm
considering the structure of all the
elements is uh um you know uh is uniform
so so in particular in general i cannot
say that a non-commutative group in
non-community group all the elements
may present multiple
multi multiple representation so in
particular this means that if i can
represent an element in multiple way
then it's going to be hard to compare to
do the equality testing with the element
so
so for example
in band psi groups so if i consider this
element x i x j inverse x i
this is equal to x j x i inverse x j
which
at the first look they look quite
different in fact you would think that
they are not the same element
but you can prove
so so essentially maybe i'll do it on
the board so if you start
with the x i
x j inverse
and then x i i can multiply on the right
by
uh x
j inverse
then
x i inver x i
and then by x j
inverse and that this will give me one
and indeed if i look at this element i
can see that this is
the repetition of the same element
uh three times so so essentially this
it's indeed correct because it's the
exponent condition that w3 is equal to
one
so
the the nice thing about this group
is that all the elements can be
represented in a very compact normal
form
so all the elements will have this
structure
so can be seen as a sequence of the
product of the generator with some
exponent but remember the exponent could
be 0 1 or 2 or for simplicity i'm using
the minus 1 notation
followed by the product
of the commutator away tool so the two
commutator again with an exponent that
could be minus one zero one
followed by the product of the three
commutators
so so this is really nice so i i am what
i'm saying is whatever element you tell
you give to me first i can convert these
in this normal form which is very nice i
has a very specific well-defined
structure so once everything is in this
normal form i can start to the
comparison even just looking at the
exponent
so
so so again so so now of course of these
i have exactly n if i also put the
exponent zero order of n if you don't
want to write that element and then this
will be of the order of m squared
because it's n choose two and this is
the order of n cube because it's n
choose 3. so so overall
the representation okay let me go back
the the representation of any element as
length n cube
the order of n cube yes
you can use the two communicators to
sort the exercise
yes and then you can push the two meters
to the right using the three commutators
and the three computers they commute
with everything so you can perfect so
it it is what you just said but i want
to prove that indeed uh it is an
efficient algorithm it's called the
collecting process and i'm gonna talk
about it in just a couple of slides the
only thing i have to prove to you that
is efficient is not exponential and
that's what i'm gonna prove it uh next
so
so but before we go to that point let me
do an example so let's fix n equals 2
and let's consider b2 so m is equal to 3
and then is equal to so just two
generators x1 and x2 and was this a
great picture here at least i think it's
great
so so essentially look at the square to
represent
uh
the elements and the edge represent the
multiplication so so if i wanna if i
start from one element here
and i uh i wanna multiply by x2 then i'm
gonna follow a purple uh edge and if i
wanna multiply by x two inverse then i
follow the edge in the reverse direction
and same thing for if i wanna multiply
by x1 so this means that i'm multiplying
this element by x1 and notice already
that if i multiply 3 times by x1 it
means that i go x1 x1 x1 so i get the
identity
so
for so these uh uh b it this is uh
called the calais graph of b2
and b2 has 27 element and they are all
written in this normal form that in this
case it just means
the first generator x1
to the exponent minus 1 0 1 depending on
the element and then x2 to another
exponent minus 1 0 1
followed by the commutator but in this
case uh two commutator which in this
case is only x1 x2 to the exponent minus
one zero one
okay so since craig is in the audience
we say okay i like that but what about
putting everything in a matrix form
uh so that i can think of them as
multiplying instead of concatenation and
for the case of b
2 this is this group b 2 is isomorphic
to the eisenberg group
so where all the elements
can
be represented as
the following matrix triangular matrix
and on the upper part i have the
exponent of the first generator the
second generator and the two commutators
so in this case
i can think of the multiplication as the
products of the two matrices that result
from writing
the two element in this matrix form
so for b2 is actually nice i have a nice
way of mapping to what is familiar to us
or where if we try to go you know b3
then
things don't map again back to to this
group so there are no known polynomial
or the representation of bien
so really if you have to
like this group you have to like
to work on this concatenation and on the
collecting process that i'm going to uh
describe in order to multiply the
element
so okay so really we have to discuss the
group operation so remember the normal
form and pictorially i'd like to for the
next slides to think of these as the red
part is the sequence of the generators
the green part is the sequence of the
two commutators and the blue part is the
sequence of the computers we discussed
before this isn't the order of n this is
order n square and this is order of n
cube
okay
so so to multiply two element we just
put one after the other but now it's not
in normal form so essentially i would
like to move the blue
toward the blue
the green all together and the red all
together
so so this uh is called the collecting
process
and i'm going to show that it takes time
order of n cube which is cubic in the in
n
but is a linear in the representation of
the element
okay so first step
first step is that
i'm gonna i know that my friends are the
commutator weight three because they
commute with everything so the first
thing i'm gonna do is to move all of
these
toward the end of w2 and then add the
corresponding exponent
second okay so so
this i have to do for all for all the
element in here and each one i move in
constant time so these require
n-cube
time
stage two well stage two i'm i wanna
take care of the green part the two
commutators so i wanna move the two
commutators sequence of the first word
w1 toward the two commutators in the uh
group in the world two
okay so let's look at the last two
commutator in the sequence when i swap
these with the first generator of the
second world this is gonna give rise to
a tree commutator so so i can swap them
but then it generates a tricommutator
which is my friend i can move it for
free toward the end and some the
exponent so for each
one
so for each one
two commutators that i consider in this
sequence i have to create these uh for
all the generator in here so for each
one of them i have to do n square
uh
running time
and then since i have
uh sorry order of n i i said the other
way around so for each one of them i do
order of an
running time since i have order of n
square i get gain order of n cube
right did i say the end correct i think
i fix it yeah
so also this so is this clear
so so also second step
takes time or drawing cube
so the last step is the tricky part so
the last step
is the one that
i have to order
in lexical graphic order
all the generators so i have all the
group of generator of word one and the
group of generator of the word two
but i have to order them my
lexicographic order but remember every
time
i swap uh
x1 with x2 i create a two commutator so
if i consider x and er and x1 here when
i swap i create the two commutator x1 xn
but now i have to move
these all toward the green part but for
each one of them i have to create a
trigger mutator that goes toward the end
so so for
fixing each out of order generator
takes order of n swaps
but before but as i said before before i
can go to the next generator i have to
fix this commutator weight too
which as i say in the previous life
takes order of n squared time since i
have order of n generators overall i
takes order of n times and squares order
of n cube
steps also for these for this third
stage so overall the three stages they
all take order of n cube time
and so overall the algorithm to multiply
to eleven two elements in the group is
in the order of n cube
the n cubed here is okay yeah because uh
in this case is uh is uh the length of
the representation of the element in the
group so in this case it's fine for this
yeah
so so just to recap so
this is the normal form
the length so the number of elements
in the end if you count it's going to be
3 to n
and choose 2 plus n choose 3 so
it's finite but it has a lot of element
on the order of 3 to the n cube
and then the feature is the group
operation is efficient
in particular is cubic in the security
parameter but is linear in the input
size
and i didn't talk about the inversion
but it's somehow similar
of concatenate because you have to swap
all w3 and then the group to generate
commutator and then the generator and
then you have to move everything
together but essentially is a simpler
description of the algorithm that i just
described so he also uh takes uh same
running time
and
it's not community commutative but enjoy
several properties that are bringing to
us to something that we are familiar
with in particular we have two important
property w3 is equal one and x1 x2 x3 x4
is equal to one
and so now what you remain to say okay
now we have this nice group
what can we say about
the hardness of assumption
i understand how you keep the normal
form but why is it important that we
keep the normal because if i can
translate all the element in the same
form then i can compare them in general
in groups
you can have yes you can have multiple
way of expressing the cell and then it
will be hard to compare them in this
case you can always convert to a normal
form but in this case the normal form is
also nice it's incompact so so the
operation the group operation is also
efficient
these are all you didn't show but these
are all different these elements
uh
yeah
yes it's not obvious
no you require proofs
so i'm gonna leave the hard part to
antonia
okay so and i'm never going to switch
slides here after we've done a window of
uh proper
binder groups and we'll uh try to see
okay so now we think we can use them as
a platform for computational operations
we know how to represent them in a
compact way we know how to operate with
them
uh so we can do things with them
efficiently the question is what's hard
to do with them
and
there that's where the pitfalls usually
arise in the case in the context of
group trading cryptography because you
go into problems like
the word problem meaning try to
recognize that the two elements are the
same and usually those problems are not
very they don't lend themselves to
average case analysis there are impr
problem for general groups not for this
one and it seems complicated to actually
develop our problems in that way so we
took a different we took a different
approach
and just so that we can you know maybe
take cut your breath with something that
we are familiar with the approach we
took was to look back at learning with
errors and see whether we would learn
something from that you know from that
approach to things so let me know you're
learning with errors although we've seen
it you know several ways during the
workshop and differently from what we've
done so far we're going to take an
algebraic look at learning with errors
there's a lot you can learn from
learning with errors but looking at this
geometrically that's you know looking at
the largest structure behind them that's
not what we're doing we're doing a
detailed brightly and there is something
also we can accelerate from that so
deciding on anywhere just to fix
notation i'm going to assume that the
secret is called s and that's a vector
of length n
and there's going to be some
perturbation using gaussian noise which
is going to be the epsilon
and then we're going to consider these
distributions over pairs which are an
element from fun a vector and the scalar
fq
obtain it by setting a random vector and
then a noisy inner product so we're
going to take an inner product with a c
test and we're going to be with gaussian
noise
so one way to look at it besides you
know inner products you think of these
as a functional linear functional so you
can take the inner product as a function
from fqn to fq
and that's all linear functions from the
vector space of qn to the base
field fq can be written as product by
some uh some vector
so really what's going on here one way
to look algebraically at lw is that
you have the secret functional from the
vector space of qn to the base
field fq and you give out pre images
together with noisy images you give out
pairs a b
where a is a random pretty image and b
is a noisy image of the second function
and then the assumption is that if you
get
access to distribution of pre-images
noisy images which is this a
distribution parameterized by the noise
distribution and with the cigarette s
then that's uni that's the distinction
from the over distribution that's the
decisional version of the assumption of
course it's also going to the search
version in our case the equivalent is
not clear so i'm going to stick with the
digital version and i'm not specifying
whether s is run or whether s is the
obvious rate because there's a worst
case to average case reduction in that
case so it doesn't matter so we can deal
with that as a lw assumption so once you
look at lw like this we can say okay so
if what's going on is that we have a
secret function a single functional
linear function from the vector space
the base field really we could even just
look at them as groups that there are no
morphemes within them sure these are
vector space over this field but it's
you know it's a group which uh in this
case with respect to addition and it's
also a group with respect to addition
their other structure but they don't
arise in this situation they do arise in
the applications of lw to photography
but not for the assumption and then you
can think of it what if i have two
separate groups gmp which don't know
which are not vector space in society
they are you know just bare bones groups
but they're compatible let's say that i
can have
homomorphis between g and p
and then the hallmark between gmp is
going to be your secret key that's going
to be the circuit and the distribution
is going to give you
random free images in this first group g
together with a noisy home orifice with
a noisy image fee of a times some noise
distribution e which you have to define
so for now i'm going to leave that
indicated just as a
size solution which is
not in a slide and we call this a
problem this generalized version of lwe
we call that learning all morphemes in
noise because the goal there is to learn
what the morpheus is of course i'm
actually going to look at the original
version so it's more like distinguish
pretty much pairs but we're going to
give the name of the learning on more
free noise so to compare and contrast
the dual assumption just one second uh
the in the case of lwe the cigarette is
a functional is an era functional
defined by the vector s and the noise is
defined by the gaussian distribution
it's a small noise in fq instead we can
always think of it as the secret is a
home or phase from a group g to another
group p and the noise must be small in
some sense
and it's in leaving the group p yes
just a
very basic question so when you consider
some analogues of standard linear
algebra over normal
is it even
without noise
no exactly
it's a very good question so the point
here is that one of the reasons we look
at lwe is because if you don't have
noise the problem is easy and
it's amazing that by adding a little bit
of noise the problem becomes hard and
you know it gives us a lot of power to
do applications in the case of
non-community algebra it's not clear
that we don't know if the problem is
easy and in fact
people have looked at that question but
we didn't feel like relying on that for
computation for cryptographic hardness
because it's difficult to make average
case
guarantees on that front but it is you
know we we don't know the new way of
solving the problem without uh the noise
either it's just that the computational
assumption becomes difficult to work
with so maybe you know that's one reason
to to to like this in a non-community
group because it seems like it's gonna
be even harder than regular lw
uh which you can
i'm saying
it's gonna be harder to apply so that's
uh indeed like towards the end i'm gonna
show that so far we only have mini grips
uh mini hip application because of the
non-community
okay so to summarize what you need to
define this is an abstract framework you
know because you can define it for any
pair of group gmp that are compatible so
you need two groups gmp
uh you need distribution over these
groups although most of them are going
to be uniform distribution here i'm
leaving open the hypothesis that maybe
that even infinite and so the uniform
distribution doesn't make sense for
infinite but what we see another one is
going to be finite anyway so you can
think of gamma as a as a uniform
distribution psi is going to be the air
distribution so that's going to take
some work
and then maybe you also need the
distribution over the
secret keys where the amorphous from g
to p although again when it's uniform
when it's finite you can go with the
uniform distribution and so the
assumption is going to be here's the
same picture from before you have a
random a from the group random pre-image
in a noisy image and then the assumption
is to distinguish those from random g
and p of course this makes sense for the
final case for the npk case you can
generalize without distributions but
we're not going to look into that here
and this distribution i'm assuming it's
in this case for a random or more phase
in general if you don't set if you don't
go into concrete settings you cannot
prove that this is equivalent to a worst
case
version where it doesn't matter and the
omorph is arbitrary
so
then let's first of all convince
ourselves you know very briefly that
this actually generalizes uh lwe and of
course it does because you just look at
the additives group inside the the
vector space fpn with the uniform
distribution they look at the other
group inside the base field of p with a
discrete gaussian as the distribution
for the noise and then of course your
homomorphis just always boils down to
linear functional those are the only
amorphous between the vectors the d
group in the vector space and the other
group in the base field
and so you get exactly the same thing so
the noise here becomes uh the addition
of the gaussian noise because the
notation is additive instead we'll be
using multivinodation these are
equivalent dps which motivated to add
denotation
so we recover lw as a generalization but
generalizations are not useful if you
don't get anything else and by the way
you also capture wrinkle inglew module
lwe and all the other generalizations
they all fit into this in this framework
the question though is can you get
something more than that and in
particular that's where we are trying to
find the suitable non-community group
and then we did a great job at
explaining you the problem we're going
to use in for this setting which is the
bronzer groups
so what you get if you use a bronzer
grouping is a learning or morphing noise
framework we call them learning burn
cytomorphism we could denote it with bn
lhn so the lhn problem is the general
problem where you don't specify the
framework so it's more like of an
abstract presentation and you said the
dnl change is the actual problem that
you are studying so we call that
learning birth cycle morph with the
noise and the way you sanchez it is for
the first group you choose the burnside
group with exponential and then
generators and it's going to be your
security parameter and instead for the
base group you choose uh another bonsai
group of small order and particularly
finite of four or five that's what you
are toying with um if you think about
the case of lwe also there if it's
finite the 3d parameter doesn't really
play a big role in uh in the base field
yeah it's fp and some type p is
polynomial so maybe it makes sense to
look at their logarithmic n in cd
parameter but it's not necessary to look
much beyond and for now we're looking at
the case of
of uh just like austin which you could
do also for lw you can imagine working
with lwe
in the case that the the prime is three
although there you cannot do the
distribution being gaussian you have to
do something like a bernoulli so it's
become more like an lpn kind of
assumption at this level abstraction
they are pretty much like equivalent to
lpn the noise distribution is a
parameter here
okay
then distribution we said over the pre
image is uniform now
turns out uh something you're going to
discuss a bit later in a bit more detail
that
the group bonsai group with energy expo
generators and the one with our
generators are compatible in a sense
that you can always
map uh you you get a lot of homomorphism
from the first to the next from the end
to to be out i'm going to say a couple
of words about that but under this set
is finite it's exponentially big in n
and so you can they just use one
distribution on that so hold on on that
i'm going to say a couple of more words
on that
and next you know a bit of like magic in
the distribution how do you go what do
you do instead of the gaussian solution
here here we do something completely
different in gaussian and you can think
of that as a random walk in the heli
graph so in any show before a picture of
a hilly graph for the example of the
burnside group of exponentry into
generators which was the the ball
uh where the quality were holding and
again the heli graph is a representation
of the group where nodes are the
elements of the group and vertices start
the group operation and because of
multiple generators this is actually a
labeled or a colored graph
and
in there
you can represent identity as you can
label one node as identity and then you
can look how far
um
how many elements there are not so far
from that entity so if you start from
identity and you only multiply by a
bunch of generators what do you get so
this expression here uh when you take a
random permutation of the generators and
you give them a response to them and
then you look at their product
correspond to starting from the entity
and then choosing one of the generators
deciding whether to use it or not they
would use it in inverted or not and then
sticking it in your expression and then
move it to the next generator decided to
use it or not and we which in index and
so forth so this is just like a
permutation of the generators some of
them may not occur because the exponent
may be zero some of them are cured
inverted so it's kind of like a random
walk over the scale graph an important
property which is the reason we we chose
that is that um
the
exponent here is completely random so
they're going to have a good
randomization property when you multiply
by by um by the the image so we're gonna
discuss that in a second
so then the problem becomes that you're
given a random a together with a noisy
image where the image is being
perturbed by this random walk in the
calligraph
so
uh
okay so
i'm gonna denote this
uh
the zero distribution with br because
like it's like a ball in this scaly
graph you're making a ball radius r
starting from the identity so that's as
much drama that we're going to be able
to recover in this setting unfortunately
by looking at it algebraically you lose
a lot of the geometry of the ldap
setting the only beta geometry you are
able to recover is through this notion
of knorr and so that's like you're going
to be defending this br as the bolts of
radius are and so the assumption we make
is that
if you're given a pair of a pre-image
together with a perturbed image by a
noise which is in the ball uh around the
dent in the heli graph that's going to
be distinguishable from a random
pre-image together with the random with
the random element in the image
and the assumption is you know the
finite for the average case and what
will prove is that in fact the
assumption is the worst case as a random
self-disability so in fact if it is true
for the average case it's also true for
the worst case if the whole morph that
you're using is actually subjective or
morpheus which is going to be with
overwhelming probability in our case
because we are going from a big set bn
into a much smaller set vr in our case
that is constant and so it's even if you
don't
worry about exactly using it as a
subjection it's going to be a subjection
with over a bit if you take it at random
so that's what i got talk in the
remaining time the last 15 minutes now
they did a great job at motivating
randoms of usability for me so i'm gonna
say very few words
uh we think that random stuff usability
gives some sort of
circumstantial evidence that the problem
is hard because if you try to break the
problem well you have an easy time at
setting the question if you can break it
for a random session uh you can choose
your own your your instance if you can
beg for any instances is bad and on the
other hand if you want to use it for
derivative application you can take a
random key random amorphous and if any
amorphous is strong a random one is
going to be strong so it's easy to use
an application it's easy to break if the
assumption is false so we think that
like you know it's an important trait
for assumption to have and the fact that
this property hold for these groups to
us
suggests that these actually are a good
distantiation of this framework
i'm not going to say much more because
like i said the daniela motivated the
uh
the importance of random sufficient
problem
so the next thing before we can actually
prove this roundness of feasibility is
to understand a bit more what the serial
keys are
like i said before in our case the sega
keys are homomorphised between these
groups between a group with the lotto
generator so this style or this family
and a group with much fewer generator of
the same family and so if you want to
try to understand how if it is to
recovery key or to figure out whether he
is being used we better understand how
this key work you know what that is on
morpheus
so an important thing you know the last
bit of background that you may need to
know to understand uh
these keys is the notion of relatively
free
this group burnside uh burnside groups
are also called free burn side groups
because they
have the property that if you take any
other group which has the exponential
condition where every element does as uh
exponentially every element of two our
trees give the identity then you can
always define a non-morph visa from the
bronzer group into this group notice
that in general it's not true that again
given in two groups you can define an
amorphous if you have zp and zq for p
and q which are
co prime
then there is no morpheus from zp to tq
other than the trivial amorphous why
because element in zp have a certain
order if it's the additive group it's p
if it's the multiple group it's female
it's the it's theopy
and the one in the queue have a
different order and so unless you do the
figure of morphine map heaven into one
it's going to be a conflict they're
gonna they're gonna be law that are true
in the first group that are not in the
second group now in the case of one cell
group the only law that's there is the
exponent three so if you have another
group of exponent three for example f3
or f3n like vector space over f3 those
have the property that every element
multiplied by three gives you the
identity gives you zero they're not
denotation then you can always have one
more phase from any birth cell group b n
into f three and f three of n and so
forth so that said you know this fact is
it's called the freeness in the
categorical group of uh of exponentry so
without going into more of the details
this is essentially it's easy to define
all morphines from bn to br because of
course br also has exponent three just
fewer generators
and the way that you do the final morph
is just to choose a mapping for the
generators of the first group so you
decide where to map the generators and
then there is exists always a unique
homomorphic that extends linearly
homomorphically
to the rest of the group
and in particular this means that in our
case we're choosing the group p to be br
for r think of r as a constant then you
get that for each of the engine readers
in the n you have a choice of three
power r arches two arches three possible
images and for each of that you get
different homomorphism so the number of
amorphous whichever case are the ziggy
keys is this kind of exponential so even
for our costa is exponential in n so our
key space is big uh even if you choose r
to be something like four okay
so
that's the first thing we need to know
about amorphies
the next thing that you need to know
about martha is that
even though we are looking at a
non-community group to try to find
additional hardness to study them you
often try to go back to the billion case
so you do what's called the nobilization
you try to look at them from a point of
view of a billion groups and
abilitization is called does come in
three shapes you take a group you can
try to ability the group you can try to
bilionize
the elements of the group and you can
try to be analyzed on all morph within
groups so let me start from mobilization
of a group the transition of the group
is just a way to say well you know they
were describing these commutators which
were what you needed to recover
abelianity so if you have in j in our
group
uh
w1 and w2 that's not equal to w2 w1 but
c equal to w2 w1 with the commutator w1
w2 so you don't get
equality you don't get ability because
you have this additional factor so what
you can say is what if i look at this as
a subgroup the sub which consists of all
communicator away two and i take the
mode and then i mod it out so that this
equation holds modulo the commutator
away too then i recover a billionth okay
so that's called the immunization
civilization
yes i mean that yeah sorry ah that's a
good point this is incorrect because you
need the normal closure so you need to
conjugate by element of the group thank
you
so here there is a mistake here is
actually this is not suffice you have to
add the conjugation by element in the
group
so
anyway once you do that if you mod out
if you mod out from the group the the
community is away too and in particular
the government's way too has a weight
three a special type of community two
when the second element is not a
generator then you go back to an a
billion case okay so that's called the
ionization of the or the burnside group
the n and which you cover there is the
vector space f3n
okay so then besides the notion of the
being installation of the group you can
look at the bionic individual element
which means how do you map an element
from the bronzer group to an element in
its urbanization
and that pretty much consists of taking
the prefix in the exponent list so in
other words the element in the bronzer
group have these long exponent lists
first exponents for all the generators
then the exponents for all the good that
is away two and then a spawn and four
could add us to a3 when you look at the
abilization essentially you are saying
modulo changes to the barn side elements
of weight two and three
then the high level information the
first order information is captured in
the first list so the base station
discards the rest of the information and
just keep
the the remaining part
and
so this will call the objection map row
then and of course let's define it for
every
b ion and br so we're going to use row
of n for the basis that is for n
generators there is another one for our
generators
uh we're going to call rho bar and the
last concept is the urbanization of the
homomorphism so if you have a new
morpheus that goes from the end to br so
it's an economic non-community group
then you can look at the homomorphism
between the corresponding observation
which in other words the way one way to
think of it is uh here you're taking an
element which has a structure you're
going to name each other signal
structure for fewer exponents because
your fewer generators so what you can do
is just look at the prefix of generators
here and look at the predictor
generators here you're going to get them
up between the corresponding vector
spaces and this map is compatible in the
sense that if you first step in eyes and
then map on your first map and then a
billion eyes you get the same place so
this diagram commute
now that's not a trivial fact it follows
from the fact that abilization are
universal for
all morphemental billion groups for barn
side and that's category theory which
happened to work nicely in the case of
bonsai group but it's not for granted
this thing would commute
so we're going to be denoting the basic
neuromorphism fee with the fee bar so
we're going to use the fee bar notation
if we uh bar somebody means that
stabilization of the corresponding home
office
all right so let's see if we can try to
understand this organization by using
them for a second and in particular one
question would be are we getting
anything new here do we
you know like a valid concern would be
easy the case that we need
the
lw problem in the community in the
billion case for a modular three do we
need that to be hard for our problem to
be hard in other words what happened if
you give me the samples a and b
are in this community which lives in his
non-community group a
is in bn and b is in br what happened if
i try to oblige them and try to break
the corresponding problem for the
billion case am i going to be able to
tell whether you are using amorphous
it's random you're doing that
so in other words if i look at the
assumption i'm making it is that
pairs of the form pre-imaging bn and
then image in vr with noise are
distinguishable from pairs in the nbr
what happened in fabianized them
albanizing them means that parabenzation
to both elements here and to both
elements here this is the easy part of
course if i be an eyes are on the middle
and then they're going to get around the
mirror on it because that's just a list
of
of the first exponents
here means all the experiments around
those and particularly these points in
the generator surround and the same for
here so this maps on the universal
distribution now what happened if iobn i
is an element here well a was also
random in bn so row a the position of
eight so i'll be uniform
about this side
here by a billion by the diagram before
i'm going to get the same thing if i
bainize the pieces and then apply the
operation after i go there which is
going to become sum because now i'm f3n
uh
f3r so in this case it's going to be the
image of a whatever it is plus the image
of the noise well that's where the
reason for choosing the noise the way we
chose was if you remember the choice was
a random list of exponents permeated
somehow now if you identify the element
all you get is only the exponent of the
generators which is just that random
from fr which means that the variation
of this noise is random and so this is
going to be the one time part is going
to be random so exhibition you get here
is actually random because you'll be
nice these into a random vector and
random because the noise
uh is going to become like a random
quantum path so in this case if your
banana is the sample you get the same
distribution that if you obey analyze
the reference distribution so there is
no way to distinguish distribution once
you organize them there is any hope of
distinguishing them is before you
bionize them after they become the same
distribution which means that
it
does not suffice to break up debris you
know even if you can break ld over f3
maybe this assumption over b3 is still
going to be hard
that doesn't mean that there is no
reduction it means that this approach
fails so i cannot prove to you that
they're independent as assumption but i
can tell you that obvious approach like
working with the validation are pretty
much the only thing that are known about
these things don't work
because if you do them then what you get
is
things that actually cannot no longer be
distinguishable
okay so
they suggest that
this is just also like to give a feeling
of how you work with urbanization now
don't have a lot of time so maybe i'm
going to stick with the intuition of how
to improve the
uh random feasibility of the assumption
it's going to be into steps the first
step is genetic actually works for all
assumptions of this type and
interestingly it's not really used much
in the case of ldb because you have so
many other properties in the case of
vector of vector spaces
um that's
true in any in any setting whatever
however houston shared it and the second
step is that is only true for the case
of b and we can only we know holy how to
prove it in the case of bn and it's
going to say that actually this
randomization trick
it's it's complete it completely
randomizes the class of keys if you
stick with the subjective syracuse
so okay so what's the first part with
the first trick the first trick we can
call it domain shuffling and what he
says is that if you take a random
permutation of the first group
and before disclosing the pre-image you
permute it according to this random
permutation
then what you get is going to be also a
sample from a distribution uh from an
ld-like distribution for a different
error for a different secret vector and
here there is that we have to choose the
inverse here is because in general
uh
we like to work with these operations in
general it's not easy to invert another
morpheus and non-commutatively so even
though it's an automorphism even though
it's a limitation of the groups it's not
easy to invert it in general so that's
why we we work it like this okay so the
statement says that if you have a sample
of the form random a and b which is phi
of a times z and you
uh preprocess the first part with the
alpha inverse then what you get is a
sample without changing b at all is also
sample according to different node
distribution and that's just simple
algebraic modification so okay what
you're saying that this thing a prime b
should look like a prime with a noisy
image of c composed with alpha on a
prime times some noise that comes from
for distribution and well if you plug
things in b is phi of a you can think of
5 a as phi alpha alpha inverse alpha
inverse of a called the prime and so you
get i prime phi composed with alpha over
prime mini so here you don't need to do
anything with the b side because on the
b side if you apply a normal phase we
don't know what happened because there
is a noise which doesn't commute so we
may actually not get what we wanted
so this doesn't completely randomize
does not completely randomize the figure
but he said that if it's
uh you can always translate your secret
by a permutation that you know
now if this permutation
is also a no morphism so it's a it's
actually an automorphism then for the
case of bonsai group we can prove that
this actually is complete meaning that
for any two subjective maps from bn to
br there is always exactly one that's
actually unique automorphism inside
beyond that moves the first into the
second such that you can look at the
neuromorph as a composition so the
previous trick was saying that if you
have an instance under phi
you can always randomize the ninja
instance under phi compose alpha but it
doesn't guarantee that the instance of
the form five compose alpha cover the
entire space instead this side it does
cover the entire space because for every
five bar for a five prime there's always
alpha that moves phi into five prime
and
the intuition of that which is a
statement that is written here
the intuition of that it's in the
following picture here the first
homomorphism goes from the end to be
hard unfortunately i'm calling five star
here i should have called if i brian the
presentation
i'm generation is called five star
and i would like to split this uh
homomorphis from bn into br into two
steps first an automorphism so a
a permutation a projection from bn into
itself
and then a no morpheme from bn into br
now it's obvious that you can always
find a map here that goes from the end
into bn such that
five star is equal to first applying the
beta and then the fee however notice
that here we're going from a big set to
a small flip so nothing prevents the two
steps from happening like you go from a
big set into some subset here and then
from this subset into the small steps
here because you have a lot of space to
lose from here to here br is much
smaller and so it could be that actually
you are losing something here and then
you're losing the rest here if that's
the case then this is not an
automorphism which means that if that
was all we only all we got you wouldn't
be clear distribution is uniform because
perhaps you get some some subjections
more often than others so what you need
is now a way to patch
the arbitrary homomorphic that you're
given by just a
in a billionaire disagreement argument
into a full
automorphism
so
um
maybe like it's gonna take some more
like a couple of minutes without going
too much into the details but
the technical level that allows us to
prove the theorem is that even though
by going to urbanization you lose a lot
of information
turns out that
a map from the end into br is subjective
so it covers the entire codomain if and
only if the corresponding immunization
is subjective now one direction is
obvious if this is subjected then this
must be subjective but what's so clear
is that if this objective suffices for
the entire team to be subjective so
one side is just a so-called diagram
chase is because you must have variety
in one direction and because we approved
already this thing commutes then you
must have uh you must be subject in the
other direction
the other side instead requires a couple
of additional uh
tools and in particular requires the
fact that nelly was pointing out before
this communicator wait for r1
the terminology is that the group is
actually important um if you start
taking factor group out of the group it
terminates soon and
that suggests that uh you can always if
you once you get a
lisa generators modulo a subgroup then
you can always bring it back to a full
list of generators and the list of
generators in here in the beginning
session is just the isogenerator model a
specific cell group the sagru the
community group bnbn
so that's why you can also generalize it
in there okay so that's essentially the
lamb i studied before uh leave it in the
specific case of uh of the bronzer
groups which is that
um
if you have uh that a list of uh you
know this is another defined list you
have m elements in vr the same elements
actually generate all of vr even though
if the corresponding urbanization
generates all of f3r and instantly you
can test by rank arguments and so you
can actually uh and this is not only an
infinite leaf but you can also recover
the the corresponding the corresponding
bases
all right so now like you know very
briefly so this is try to suggest that
this is viable from the point of view of
hardness that you get some heart problem
you know we don't really know too much
about this problem other than random
self-reducible would suggest that you
know if you want to try to break them
you should have an easy time breaking
them so if people can break them
of course could mean that they don't
care but often people at some point are
going to start to care and then if they
cannot break then that's because the
problem is art the other side though is
actually using them for applications now
it's clear that the assumption already
gives you some sort of still randomness
so building certain generators is pretty
simple meta from that and so what you
get as a corresponding encryption scheme
is something similar to
uh you know like in a sense you can
think of that as you know something same
to robin encryption where you have two
different type you know the residuals
model uh the squares and you know
residues and encrypted zero with the the
the residue center one with the null
residues here what you do you need to
uh look a bit more again to the geometry
of the group which has to do with the
scaling arm turns out that this group
have a pretty big diameter so there
always exists elements which requires a
lot of generators and inverses to write
and for this reason you can always have
a way to tell whether you have added you
sneaked inside an element a copy of a
large unit or not so one way to get the
encryption is to
fix one such element which exists by
hounding argument and then in the small
case in this case in the case of small
group you can do an exhaustive search to
find them so you fix an element which
has a large so-called kali norm meaning
that the only way to express it as a
product of generators and inverses it
takes a long sequence and then to
encrypt a zero you just give a sample
from the uh distribution a and b and so
here i'm missing a power t so the
encrypted zero should be in just a b and
you grip the one
then you send a together with the tau t
by the b now because the norm of b is
always going to be
small
then when you look at the distance
between
pi of a and b prime when you apply the
amorphies somebody who knows the
secretomorphis then can compare
whether these two elements uh
are nearby or not and if they are nearby
then if the distance is small then you
assume that the old vertebration was due
to the noise if they are not nearby then
you supplementation was due to the
presence of the big toe
because it doesn't follow from the
correct and that's the reason why r is a
constant
we don't know that it's not easy to
compute but you don't know how to
compute it so right now we pre-compute
the entire norm and it's also how we
know the sizes there are bounds on the
sizes but the bound that you get just by
the bonds that you improve are not great
when you actually do the configuration
uh then you see that the these elements
are actually pretty big so you could be
able to sneak maybe more than a bit
maybe like five bits
uh
but that's you know those are constants
that's a good point the computational
killer norms is not um in general is not
known to be polynomial time it could be
for these kind of groups but nobody has
a look at them so we don't know if these
are easy to complete or not
we don't need them in this case because
we're working with the call center
so
the message encoded the message
there's a missing t here
uh if the message is zero you don't
include the tau if the message is one
she's like you know the way to beat
enclave but with the debris when you
hide q over two or you don't add q over
two
um
yeah so that's pretty much like that's
pretty much true for all the type of lhn
assumptions now in this case you also
have an hardness uh for the
corresponding assumption and the reason
why this would be the mandatory secure
is because if the assumption is true
then a b looks like a random pair but if
this were a random pair then this would
be random and so there is no difference
this this is one-time pod so
it's like a bidet show one template so
they show you the grip
now already going beyond uh
sorry going beyond minicrypt and try to
get publicly uh cryptography you start
to get a challenge you could try to do
the same trick as
uh lwe which is you include a bunch of
encryptions of zero in the public key
and then the encryptor with the public
key take a random subset however here
non-community bites you because if you
do as a random subset now the order
matters
things are no longer going to commute
you don't know that adding lots of small
noises is going to be a small noise it
is a small noise if they're all one
after the other but if they are inter
intertwined with the regular items you
don't know and even for the case of
barnes group you know it doesn't work
out now there are tricks you can try to
play with the noise distribution try to
use a resolution that commutes so that
actually it's gonna work out but that's
going to
cause the problem of
you remember when i was showing the
connection with lwe that there is no
connection by abelianity if you use
another type of
error which is which has a billionty
here
then you require lw so it doesn't make
sense to use an air distribution which
is a billion otherwise you essentially
may as well just work with ldp
so already going beyond
and getting something like uh public
encryption is tricky it requires some
sort of generalization of the leftover
schlemmer where instead of doing
inner products you do you know you look
at these homomorphisms and we think
something like that may be there but we
don't have a
specific result
so this point that concludes pretty much
uh this uh exploration
so what we've done is to first of all
look at an algebraic look at that w from
an algebraic point of view and you don't
get as much as looking for it of the
geometric point of view but you still
get something different
and then we couple that with the
exploration of these bonsai groups which
are a different type of mathematics
which is not used a lot in our community
they have a lot of structure and they
may also be useful for other
coding applications but we've tried
something like that with not much luck
it looks like you should also have
information to radical
use of them
and then we studied the hardness of one
of this assumption and in particular
we're able to prove that the randoms are
reducable one thing we're working on and
it doesn't seem to be
working easily is a decision to search
which is the case for debris but there
seem to require
the the fact that you're working over
the field so here we lose like half of
the structure
and those arguments don't go through as
well
so with that i'm gonna let you go and
catch your luggage or go to san
francisco
but if you want you could frequently ask
us questions
before you head off
so to what extent are we
confident that the problem is indeed
hard
and would you go to the extent of
removing the noise to encourage people
to cryptanalyze it maybe you know
without the noise
i think without the noise like we lose
the randoms of feasibility
so
without the noise i wouldn't be
confident we didn't always be confident
to even suggest like small parameters
like 50 generators
because it's not clear the security
parameters number generators but the
size of the group is cubic it's
exponential in the cube of that and
you know unless there are nice things
you can do then that should be enough
uh you know if not then you may need to
have like something like hundred
generators yeah without noise uh you
don't have random self-reducibility is
it like that the problem becomes easy
for anamorphisms
so okay so what i mean is that uh it
became it's gonna require lw uh let's
see
yeah i mean i don't know that actually i
don't know if you don't have it i don't
i cannot prove it
i don't know if you don't have it i
cannot prove random survivability if
there is no but
i don't know if they
shouldn't
uh should it also work when should your
proof also work when there's no error
how does the how's the error essential
for uh for the random subject yeah
you're right actually maybe not for the
proof there was something
the only thing i could think of
would be that uh i don't know you need
endomorphisms for um
uh
for your random self-reduction and maybe
the problem becomes easy for easier for
uh
if it's not noisy
yeah yeah we eventually you know somehow
like we felt like having the noise there
was a uh as an edge was like as a as an
additional safety we haven't looked too
much in the case but i think it would be
already interesting to break it without
noise so that you know we know that lw
you know it's true that we don't noise
so be interesting to know
what's the best you can do without noise
there ready to
i i wouldn't expect it to be easy but
you don't necessarily expect that you
can get hardness results so that's why
we're not looking in there but that's
from the retiree from the view actually
would be a great first step
thank you
but there are no more questions let's
thank antonio